نتواجد الان في شارع البحر تحديدا في
بدايه الشارع من الناحيه الشرقيه هذا
المكان ومنطقه عمليات للاحتلال هناك سيطره
ناريه على هذا المكان من قبل سواء طائرات
الاحتلال او اليات الاحتلال التي تطلق
نيرانها احيانا وكذلك قذائفها باتجاه هذا
المكان واي تحرك للمواطنين في هذا المكان
هذا المكان ايضا تعرض لعمليات قصف من قبل
اليات الاحتلال كما تشاهدون بعض المحلات
او المحال التجاريه في هذا المكان تعرضت
لتدمير واسع جراء سقوط قذائف مدفعيه هي
اطلقتها الاليات المتواجده في هذه او في
اقصى الشمال من وسط محافظه خار يونس اضافه
الى بعض المنازل منازل المواطنين التي
تعرضت لعمليات قصف هنا ركام احد المنازل
او الطوابق التي تم استهدافها من قبل
مدفعيه الاحتلال وادى ذلك تستمعون في
خلفيه الصوت الى اصوات انفجارات بين الحين
والاخر اضافه اصوات اطلاق نار نتيجه
الاشتباكات التي تندلع بين الحين والاخر
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه و كذلك قوات
الاحتلال في محور وسط محافظه خنوس تحديدا
الى الشمال من وسط محافظه خنوس حيث شارع
ال الكتيبه وكذلك منطقه المحطه اضافه الى
شارع خمسه الذي يتواجد فيه تتواجد فيه
اليه الاحتلال حركه المواطنين في هذه
المنطقه محدوده جدا حسب توصيف الاحتلال
بان هذه المنطقه منطقه عمليات
للاحتلال فيصعب تحرك المواطنين فيها وكل
من يتحرك فيها يتعرض احيانا لعمليات قصف
من قبل طائرات الاحتلال او عملي اطلاق نار
من قبل الطائرات المسيره وكذلك مدفعيه
الاحتلال التي تطلق قذائفها كما تشاهدون
في الصوره الان هذا اثار اثار هنا القصف
المدفعي الذي اصاب هذه العماره عماره جاسر
الواقعه في شارع البحر
واثار التدمير الذي لحق باحدى الشقق
السكنيه في هذه العماره
يعني هذه الصوره في وسط المحافظه اصوات
اطلاق نار اشتباكات قذائف مدفعيه بين
الحين والاخر وحركه محدوده للمواطنين في
هذا الشارع في وسط محافظه خنوس بسبب
استمرار عمليات القصف والعمليه العسكريه
التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال في محافظه
خانيونس
لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان يونس